hi I'm Kim from Khan Academy and I'm
here with Megan who leads us teacher
education hi Megan hi Kim
in this video we are going to walk you
through the Khan Academy learner or
student experience so Megan who is
considered a learner on Khan Academy
I can't Academy we believe that everyone
is a learner and from the teacher
perspective all of your students are
learners and you can be as well that's
great so where should teachers start if
they want to better understand the
student experience on Khan Academy to
begin you want to log into your Khan
Academy account then select the
navigation button indicated by your name
on the top right of the screen once you
see the drop down menu select learner
home you can ask you the learner
homepage on your screen you can think of
this as a student's homepage as this is
what students see immediately when they
log in to Khan Academy also a quick tip
if the student clicks on the Khan
Academy logo no matter what page they
are on a swing they are logged in they
will always be taken back to this
homepage on the left hand side any
classes the student is in and where the
teacher has given them some sort of
assignment or goal is listed as you can
see the course mastery goals and
assignments recommended by the teacher
are accessible with a single click
within the assignments tab learners can
easily see upcoming assignments and work
directly on the assignments from there
within the course mastery tab learners
can see the mastery goals you have given
them and their progress towards it by
going down to the progress tab students
can see their activity log this exact
same report is also available to you as
a teacher when you click into a student
on your roster we surface the report to
both facilitate accountability and to
stimulate student-teacher conferencing
on progress by scrolling down and
clicking on teachers students can see
all of their current teachers and also
join a new class by entering a class
code one more thing
on this page students will also find a
summary of their recent activity energy
point and bad design this seems like a
really useful place for students to
check current mastery progress
assignments and overall learning can you
walk us through what students experience
when they select their mastery goals of
course Kim when students click on their
mastery goal they are taken to the
course page where they can work through
the course at their own pace what you
see here on the course page are the
different units that make up the course
as well as the students progress towards
mastering each unit below each unit name
are the lessons within each unit by
clicking into a lesson or unit I am
taken to the unit page from here
students have the option to either dive
straight into practice which they can
find on the right-hand side or first
check out the learning material which
are the articles and videos on the
left-hand side there are a couple types
of practice activities in Khan Academy's
mastery system exercises which are
opportunities for students to learn
single skills in isolation or
assessments where students get mixed
skill review the different types of
assessments address different quantities
of content quizzes are mixed review of
skills in a lesson unit tests are mixed
review of skills within an entire unit
and course challenges are a mixed review
of skills from the entire course and how
does Khan Academy assess students
proficiency in the skills they're
learning a student's work through the
content Khan Academy assesses their
skill level giving them a designation of
attempted familiar proficient or
mastered these levels are surfaced in
the teacher progress reports but
students can also quickly understand
their level by looking at the tower
visual next to each skill one brick for
from
two per profession and the crowd is
unlocked at master when students work on
skills in isolation the maximum level
they can get to is proficient they would
need to answer all the questions in
isolated skill practice correctly to get
to that level the only way to get to
mastered is by improving students can
ace questions related to that skill in a
mixed scale context so they need to
complete the assessments for that final
level up if students have tried the
skill and get 70 to 99 percent correct
we call them familiar if they are less
than 70%
they are attempted I saw a banner for
mastery challenges on the course page
what our mastery challenges great
question Kim Basinger challenges our way
for students to review and practice
previously learned skills in a course
they first get unlocked after the
student has gotten too familiar on at
least three skills and continue to get
unlocked every 12 hours afterwards they
also provide another way beyond unit
tests and course challenges for students
to level up or down in already familiar
skills mastery challenges highlight
opportunities for students to engage in
personalized spaced repetition of the
skills students have already started
practicing research shows that spiraling
skills over time and across lessons is a
key component to minimizing student
learning loss and improving knowledge
retention you mentioned that students
can see assignments from teachers how do
students know which assignments to
complete from the learner home page
students can select assignments from the
left-hand panel under each class
students will see active or current
assignments and the order of what is due
soon at the top of each lift each
assignment will show the title of the
assignment the class name the due date
and the status of the assignment if the
assignment is a video or article it will
show us completed or not completed if
the assignment contains questions it
will show the students past score by
clicking on the assignment name or the
status which will show as a start button
for new assignments the student
we'll be taken directly to the
assignment if students want to revisit
past assignments they can click the tab
for past assignments on the top of the
page this is so helpful Meghan thanks so
much we hope this video provides a
better understanding of the student
experience on Khan Academy